les comptes quand même dans le rouge
alors c'est pas vrai cette année les
comptes sont excédentaires c'est 900
millions d'euros vous contestez les
chiffres c'est les chiffres du corps ça
c'est les chiffres généraux c'est
excédentaire le déficit du régime des
retraites il est à horizon 2027 sauf que
que disent les spécialistes c'est qu'on
ne réforme pas un régime parce qu'il est
déficitaire dans 5 ans les retraites
c'est pour toute une vie et même plus
c'est à dire qu'il faut réformer à
horizon 2050 ou 2070 et qu'est-ce qu'on
voit à cet horizon c'est que finalement
ça s'équilibre peu au proue et que on
est sur des déficits qui s'y ils peuvent
exister sont assez légers on est même en
2027 entre 0,8 et 1% de nécessité de
redresser maintenant
de réformer il y a pas de nécessité
immédiate et si on se dit qu'il faut
parce que on a les effets d'augmentation
des dépenses qui sont liées notamment à
la génération des baby-boomers on peut
avoir ponctuellement un besoin de
financement mais alors il y a pas
absolument besoin de repousser l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite c'est 12
milliards d'euros qu'il faut trouver 12
milliards vous évoquiez à l'instant une
suppression d'un impôt à 8 milliards
d'euros donc d'un côté
d'un côté on supprime un impôt sur les
entreprises de 8 milliards d'euros et de
l'autre on fait travailler les Français
deux ou trois ans de plus vous rendez
compte de l'injustice total enfin je
veux dire on n'a pas besoin aujourd'hui
d'aller chercher de l'argent sur la vie
des Françaises et des Français parce que
ce qui se passe quand on repousse l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite c'est
qu'on renforce les inégalités parce
qu'on sait très bien qu'aujourd'hui
entre les 5% les plus pauvres et les 5%
les plus riches il y a 13 ans de
différence d'espérance de vie et que
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé des
travailleurs les plus pauvres
aujourd'hui c'est à peine quelques
années après l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite donc ce qu'on veut c'est
simplement supprimer le droit à la
retraite des plus pauvres et bien ça on
ne peut pas l'accepter et ça sera une
ligne rouge c'est une ligne rouge
évidemment c'est inacceptable et nous
serons mobilisés pour cela parce que on
l'a vu 12 milliards d'euros enfin 12
milliards d'euros 8 milliards d'euros
par rapport au budget total des
retraites c'est pas
[Musique]